bien se me ha pedido que haga algunos
vídeos sobre concavidad puntos máximos y
mínimos puntos de inflexión y esos temas
que se ven usualmente en un curso de
cálculo de primer semestre y eso es lo
que voy a hacer pero antes de que aborde
un problema como esos que encuentras en
los libros
quisiera mostrarte el aspecto intuitivo
sobre todo porque usualmente en las
clases de cálculo te dan reglas como si
el signo de la segunda derivada es
positivo la concavidad es así si el
signo de la segunda derivada es negativo
entre la concavidad desde esta otra
manera la gente memoriza las reglas se
las memorizó bien entonces pasan los
exámenes pero el hecho es que cuando
ellos llegan a tener 30 años ya es casi
seguro que se olvidaron de las reglas y
esto es inútil excepto que tu objetivo
sea nada más pasar los exámenes así que
te voy a algunos aspectos intuitivos
esperando que estos aspectos intuitivos
sean realmente aprendidos cuando
aprendes cálculo por primera vez hay
muchos sobre funciones tomás de lo que
yo voy a hablar en este vídeo pero hay
tres puntos interesantes sobre curvas
que quiero mencionar hagamos una curva
supongamos que la curva se ve algo así
aquí tenemos el eje x poco grueso aquí
el eje y supongamos que la curva se ve
algo así
aquí empieza a bajar
o sea algo así con todas estas curvas en
cálculo vas a ver muchas curvas
distintas como esta correspondientes a
polinomios de diversos grados cuáles son
los puntos interesantes los puntos
interesantes son cuando la pendiente es
igual a cero y aquí donde es la
pendiente igual a cero
déjame usar la herramienta adecuada para
mostrarte lo
aquí tenemos un punto aquí la pendiente
es igual a 0 pues si trazas la recta
tangente vas a encontrar que es igual a
0 aquí tenemos otro punto interesante
otro punto donde la pendiente es igual a
0 y aquí también la pendiente 0 si bien
no es una recta tangente porque cruza la
curva pero por así decirlo se aplana en
esa región así que estos son los tres
puntos que tú encuentras en el curso del
primer semestre de cálculo cuando estás
graficando y buscando valores extremos
este punto de aquí es un máximo un
máximo local si fuera el valor máximo de
toda la gráfica de la función sería un
máximo global este de aquí es un punto
mínimo un mínimo local y si la gráfica
se extendiera por aquí hacia arriba y
por acá también hacia arriba este sería
un punto mínimo global y este aquí es un
punto inflexión pues no es ni un máximo
ni mínimo pues la gráfica por así
decirlo aquí cambia de flexión
estudiamos un poco estos puntos veamos
si podemos tener un poco de intuición
acerca de qué es lo que pasa con la
gráfica la primera y la segunda derivada
en estos puntos empecemos con los puntos
máximos
o no mejor vámonos a los puntos mínimos
pues desaparecen bastante frecuente como
en iguala x cuadrada y en las palabras
que ven hacia arriba y por supuesto si
tenemos una parábola negativa aparece
como esto de cualquier manera estudiamos
puntos mínimos donde la concavidad es
hacia arriba supongamos que el punto
mínimo viene así esta es la gráfica de
la función
no sé no sé qué funciones en específico
pero ya me mole
fx entonces qué está pasando con la
pendiente cuando vamos de aquí
hacia acá tomemos algunos puntos y
veamos si al graficar la pendiente
captamos el aspecto intuitivo de esta
situación si tomamos un punto aquí la
pendiente se va a ver como esto
si tomamos otro punto aquí me estoy
moviendo hacia la derecha valores
positivos de x entonces la pendiente se
verá algo así entonces qué está
sucediendo aquí es negativa bastante
negativa y aquí aunque también es
negativa es menos negativa que el punto
anterior y si vamos al punto mínimo
la pendiente la pendiente de la recta
tangente ahí es horizontal y por
supuesto la derivada y es 0 y después de
este punto que pasa aquí si gráfica mos
la pendiente sigue aumentando de hecho
ya es positiva 3 aquí fue muy negativa
menos negativa se hizo 0 positiva y si
la gráfica vamos aquí es mucho más
positiva veamos si podemos graficar esto
simplemente para tener la intuición
obviamente no he dado ningún tipo de
valores no tenemos valores precisos para
la derivada entonces que tenemos aquí la
derivada es negativa bastante negativa
pongámoslo de manera arbitraria aquí
valor negativo bastante grande luego en
este siguiente punto es menos negativa
quiere decir que el valor de la derivada
estar por acá luego aquí que pasa en el
punto mínimo la derivada se hace cero
continuamos hacia la derecha la derivada
es positiva un poco positiva y luego
para el último punto es bastante
positiva entonces la pendiente este es f
prima de x si la famosa gráfica sería
creciente estoy suponiendo polinomio
segundo orden si fuera de tercer orden
esto tendría curvatura tenemos entonces
que la gráfica de la pendiente se va a
ver algo así
y esto ese sentido pues sí veámoslo
supongamos que esté la función que igual
a x cuadrada b y aquí tenemos este cfd x
entonces f prima de x sería 2a por x + 0
esta es una línea recta que pasa por el
origen aunque no necesariamente tiene
que hacerlo espero que esto te de la
intuición necesaria pero ahora pasemos a
la segunda derivada la pendiente de la
pendiente para dibujarlo aquí
la segunda derivada después está
viniendo a casa tengo que terminar este
vídeo antes de que llegue lo contrario
tendré que terminarlo mañana llamó hace
cinco minutos me tengo que apurar bueno
esta es mi prima de x o la segunda
derivada y qué pasa con la segunda
derivada la segunda derivada es la
pendiente de la primera derivada y cuál
es la pendiente aquí en este caso es una
pendiente constante que se mueve hacia
arriba así que la segunda derivada aquí
podríamos evaluar directamente sería 2a
de acuerdo se va a ver así va a ser un
número constante y positivo bien así que
en general cuando la gente cuando tú
estudias puntos extremos valores
extremos diestros puntos mínimos máximos
etcétera etcétera la manera de pensarlo
es si tú tienes digamos un valor mínimo
un punto mínimo como este de aquí
entonces hay que fijarse tenemos que
fijarnos en las pendientes alrededor de
él la pendiente se está incrementando
constantemente
aunque en este punto por ejemplo el
valor de fx está decreciendo la razón a
la que lo hace es cada vez menor la
pendiente de hecho crece empieza a
decrecer cada vez menos se hace cero y
luego empieza a crecer entonces sabes
que tienes un punto mínimo cuando la
pendiente está creciendo del mismo modo
sabes que la concavidad es hacia arriba
cuando la segunda derivada es positiva
espero que esto te dé la intuición de lo
que pasa cuando tienes un punto mínimo y
la concavidad es hacia arriba qué pasa
cuando tienes lo opuesto
bueno en casi todo lo que hemos visto
sucede lo opuesto sí que tenemos la
curva este es el eje x si este es tu
curva entonces aquí tenemos una
pendiente que es muy grande luego es un
poco menos positiva pero menor aquí
llega a ser cero luego se hace negativa
luego se hace muy negativa y aquí es
extremadamente negativa vemos entonces
que la tasa de cambio de esta pendiente
es negativa a lo largo de esta curva
cuando pasa por este máximo y en esta
curva que es cóncava hacia abajo
entonces como se ve esta pendiente en
este ejemplo si yo gráfica de la
pendiente la pendiente se va a ver algo
así ok
aquí tenemos un valor muy grande para la
pendiente que se ve reflejado aquí luego
empieza a disminuir posteriormente se
hace cero y luego se hace negativa de
manera análoga si grafica mos la segunda
derivada como se ve
la segunda derivada va a ser la
pendiente de esta función va a ser un
número negativo se va a ver de la
siguiente manera si aquí tenemos nuestro
eje x aquí vamos a tener esta función
pasa por un número negativo suponemos
que este es el punto cero cero en fin el
tiempo se me está acabando bueno no se
está acabando pero no quiero correr
esto es para valores máximos y mínimos y
en el próximo vídeo te daré aspectos
intuitivos acerca de puntos de inflexión
y luego haremos un montón de ejemplos de
los que ves en los libros de texto de
cálculo pero quise hacer esto para que
te des cuenta que no hay nada mágico en
estas reglas que establecen que si tomas
la segunda derivada y expositiva la
función es cóncava hacia arriba y si
tomas la segunda derivada y es negativa
entonces las funciones cóncava hacia
abajo esas reglas que usualmente tienes
que memorizar pero que espero haya sea
preciado que son bastante intuitivas y
también espero que sea intuitivo que
cuando tienes la primera derivada igual
a cero la pendiente cero y estás en
alguno de estos puntos que son
interesantes en este contexto
haré el siguiente vídeo sobre puntos de
inflexión y después haré un montón de
problemas nos vemos pronto